unless they were like migs in silence of
the lambs and then through their nuts
remember when the nut hits the hair yeah
i've seen that that's a movie when it's
on i have to watch it if i'm going
through
we watched it last night last night
again because our we have a niece my
niece lives with us
and that's one of her um required
readings as silence of the land what do
you mean for school no no r
we have a list of movies that's crazy
yeah yeah i i really i really enjoy
that movie and i always i always ask you
know who's worse or who's scarier
buffalo bill or um
hannibal hannibal lecter hands down
because buffalo bill
learned from hannibal [ __ ] hold on i
never thought of it
yeah but buffalo bill's scarier because
he would lure you
can you help me put this couch in my
truck
and you're like yeah no problem and then
you're in a well first of all
let's go back to that the chances of me
dying because my therapist is a murderer
is very high
because i i okay if if
if buffalo bill is helping you carry a
couch
right because that's what she does
that's what he does he watches right
but whenever you're helping somebody
with the couch everyone knows right
you don't back it out yeah you you push
it you're the one
in the front even if it goes can you
back it no you back it in because that's
the harder part
and i'm [ __ ] helping you buffalo
that's true right that's like she was
like
oh back out into the thing but you know
why why
because she was a great big fat person
she was roomy
she was roommate yeah and she could
handle a couch that heavy
yeah he picked he's like you're about a
size 8 right
and then that's why he picked her yeah
but but oh my god he kept him alive for
three days so you have
three days to sort yourself out wherever
hannibal lecter he just went he bit your
face right away
yeah i like that approach better i'd
like to be quick there we go
but you could also endear yourself to
hannibal and you could get inside of his
head and play mind games
he would never e see hannibal he has a
code
yeah and his code is you know clarice
he would never [ __ ] with her no right
the dudes that he would eat are people
that probably he thought
was beneath them or there was some sort
of like
psychological thing going on they were
troubled his excuse
well his thing was they were already
going to do it themselves like that
last guy that he killed whose face they
found in the garage yeah
remember he was like he was he was
already in you know
right not good in the head i just don't
like wells
i don't like wellesley yeah tiki tiki
tembo no si rambo chari bari
brucie pit perry pembo you know that
[ __ ] book
you guys have children that you never
read ricky ticky tim bono
it's about the chinese kid that falls
down the well
and about it the reason okay there's two
sons the elder son is
it's a book by the way it's a book and
he falls down the well and his brother
gets a short name
chang because he's the second son and
his mother doesn't give a [ __ ] about him
so the kid falls down the world take a
tiki temple and ozarombo try by ruchi
pit perry pembo and chang can't get the
words out fast enough
so the brother almost dies in the well
the point of story is give your children
short names yeah that's how the chinese
people started giving their children
short names
what else happens well the thai is the
ring the ring is a well too
oh remember that i don't like that one
adam i don't like that either i don't
like creepy kids
i don't like anything with kids except
for poltergeist
but even that i'm more of um i'm not
into
um exorcisms anything relating to like
the catholic church amount
really creeps me out deeply anything
else i can deal with
yeah so anyway um we showed her silence
in the lab we've been showing
my niece she's my niece too we've been
showing her great things
i think she's going to grow up to be a
murderer we showed her silence in the
lambs
seven seven oh that one's scary too the
korean one
yeah a couple korean movies all revenge
you gonna watch the movie i saw the
devil okay is it on uh
the apple tv yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
it's a korean movie it's very good i
love it old boy
i love that that's old school jam right
there what oh boy
poster yeah yeah yeah so old boy we
showed her we're showing her all kinds
of educational
for her to grow i want to talk about
indian matchmaking
i love did you watch it with her i don't
know much about it please to inform me
well maybe if you spend some time
with kalila and all right you know what
all right okay
you know what guys could have some
shared interest oh okay christine
okay rebuttal can i have a robot defend
my favorite cuddly baby i love to cuddle
i'm a cuddler too
come on over and i beg tom's not a
cuddler
can you please all i want is for you to
spoon me
for 15 years i beg beg and i forced him
to do it i'm hot
i'm hot yeah i'm like